20話だっただろうか俺が他市からまだ youtube で登録させ方ほんと5万円
とか6000010万くらいだったからそれくらいだった時に親しようと子と呼ばれた
時通りその時私は応援し男と呼ばれるのが嫌で
キング誘導でものを食べ器具言うととはつきあい塗っている隠しメニューのこと
スピアーノメニューにあるサイトの中では最大のメガ牛丼の
ん
2個分のアイスキング言うというものがございますぼく隊員撮影で弓道ん食べる気が
いろいろあったんですけども
私マジで柔道を食べるのが早くなっております25年間生きてきた中で防火の食が
細かったぜ人は細いしてガリガリだからそもそも食べるんじゃないイメージがあるとど
んですけどそれを払拭する際最近すぐに行くデュー dope ですが早いなぜかと
いうと去年に小休止していたからその反動もあって弾くに対するモチベーション食べ
たいですのハングリー精神が1360
5倍高いんですよ1年間に食ってないからも肉を食べることに
すごいありがたみ感謝 this ペット精神がすごいかつ最近よく組んでで最近者
金融のお店でパーって食ってみたんですけどもうちょっと何カッ
ぺちゃくちゃ喋りながらへへっだったら10分で食べました
焼けないですか king yard 10分ですよねそこそこ早いと思うんですよ
北4体も図る
先日といろんなユーチューバーとか彼の僕もタイもちょっと調べてみましょう
ん
そうなんだ8僕が2014年に食べたとき2014年3月に食べたときは
120分約120分かかっておりますそれがいいですよ細かったのは遅いんです
そしてリベンジ2016年の10月に食べたときは約20分かかっていますじゃあ2年
ごとに行っているのかな
2010年が尺20分2000円
16年が20分とず今から2019年バージョンを出しますで他の湯千葉記録も見ると
だ方が12分45秒ああああまあきょうちゃんが事態や
あれねリタイヤさん
プリッとチャンネルが9分56秒まあまあ
ボンボン tv りっちゃーんとえっちゃん二人で14分36秒
する tb 37分9秒食べ連通することしかできキャラ台数 tv 後いうが6分
30秒
た方が18分18秒誰か分からんという意味でパッと見た感じユーチューバー菜食が
だいたいエロップさん
水秒
えっそんなことできるのはいいでしょ今日の私は気合いが違います
まあ自己ベスト記録20分を超えるの当たり前にそして可能であればユーチューバーで
一番内科勤務いうのを食べきりたいときで一人で食べていてもこうなんか記録が伸びな
そうなんでドライバ望みしました
はいいい水案は望みですよろしく問屋ちなみにキングゲート食べたことありますか
多分ないと思い
ます
ああっないと思います
あんですよねありますありますねす予選ありましたありました
ないですないですよねハイネスとなりに飛びを置いといて
金融と空とさらにタイムに進むじゃないかって言う名をとりあえずメーカーとしてと
あぁ私お隣で食べていただけるかハイパスカリます次でユーチューバーで一番亭牛丼の
早い男に俺は
なりましょう
ああああああ
元気になったんですよパラダイス予選キング牛丼くださいでは富の強力空気をで
合造車4-10時間します責めたくてず2010年に市内67僕は抜きたいですはい
ずっと目標下げるお願いいただきます用意スタートています
[音楽]
今まで1円と思いません
[拍手]
[音楽]
んだけど2ね
ええええええ
ann えっえっえっ
[音楽]
ああああああ
またでの本ぞす
tue
ん
どっちん
小澤です
[音楽]
寒い寒いようですいい
よってねーってには30にビビる
ます
far
[音楽]
ん
去年ちょっと
ぐらいやばいをずっとせていただきますん
[音楽]
視聴していた
ですか
[音楽]
あわーわー進先生のな操作
me
はいはい
めちゃくちゃ
稼いで田舎なっています8分
35秒
がめっちゃ早いですよねこれめちゃくちゃ約しまった
[音楽]
me
うううう
car
あっはぁ
破風山残業はめちゃくちゃ早く多分やー多分これボク霞んでますけど僕こそ速そうと
フェース本当にやばい
あっ僕はさあ今回三者さんですかあんぽんたん434 f
多分工夫
なかなかだと思います夏のちゃんアップや最も強いなかった厚バグっちゃった
めちゃくちゃだ花ってすごくパック35分お腹のが早いんだよ
ぜひ偶然地ある方は挑戦してみてはいかがでしょうかはい
amaran